que toi tu es un mec qui en manquent
énormément à la preuve qui lierait d'un
dernier tournage pour avoir alors scellé
alors on a failli pétanque et avec nos
et bastien grimal alors raffin il ya
quelques jours j'ai posté une vidéo
ouais c'était un coup de gueule on dit
donc voila moi je ne supporte plus de
voir tous ses bébés de télé relève est
mis en avant
on revoit ses images on en parle juste
après les candidats de télé réalité ont
des enfants et qui font instagram
mais sur la tête de ma mère vous
respectez pas votre enfant en fait un
enfant ça se protège quand vous êtes un
enfant c'est pour qui c'est pour les
gens et pour la communauté où c'est pour
vous je comprends pas c'est pour gagner
plus d'argent c'est pourquoi sur la
ville ma mère je comprends avoir protégé
les vos enfants arrêtez de faire des
instagram c'est pas possible
dans quel monde on vit sur la vie de ma
mère ils ont deux mois les diamants
instagram
mais arrêtez arrêtez alors bastien
bastien vous êtes plutôt vous êtes
plutôt pour une fois ça vous dérange pas
ouais moi ça me dérange pas je suis
plutôt pour et puis surtout j'ai été
très surpris de voir cette vidéo que tu
as fait tant donné que toi tu es un des
grands exemples des gens qui ont vendu
leur vie privée à la télé alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez d'autre part
donner des cours de respect des enfants
aux gens alors que toi tu es un mec qui
en manquent énormément la preuve qu'il
fait virer d'un dernier tournage pour
avoir alors cela alors je rappelle que
j'ai encore du matériel de chirurgie
dans mon genou je ne peux pas tout alors
alors alors alors je fais parce que je
suis donc je disais 2 2 non moi il y
aura les deux on parle d on parle du
fait de mettre des enfants après que lui
mais sa vie privée sur les réseaux où on
peut discuter sa légitimité dans ce
n'était pas aussi mais il peut être
choquer mais toi tu en as non ça je te
pose est ce que tu as des enfants
non je n'ai pas y avoir non t'es venu
faire quoi ici et toi t'as fait quoi une
jeune homme était venu on vient ici
qu'on n'est pas copains on se connaît
pas tous et très bien j'attends pays et
de tuer leurs titres et après tu fais le
malin tu as vu je suis pas venu là pour
parler de quoi que ce soit ben tu fais
mal à l'assumer jusqu'au bout et puis
après quand tu as porté plainte
tu as vu nous on n'est pas là pour ça tu
vois
non mais moi j'avais une belle foire
était alors majeure est attendu ici pour
parler calmement moi j'ai un plateau
télé à venir oh mais non ya pas de coups
de pressions c'est clair donc si on a on
arrête mais je n'ai pas ok pourtant
quelle maman alors qu'elle m'a dit
pourquoi baille et 2 contres sans
menacer son adresse mais je viens mais
fermement m'écouter où la joie qui se
lisait révolté pas vous tapez un nom
vient sinon faut arrêter ça prenne des
années que ouais cauxois choqué
paternité mais mes inspecteurs ont déjà
les mains je suis je suis qui je vis et
je me remets oui mes besoins je t'aime
maman si on ne respecte pas je peux
parler qui vous attend des pionniers les
femmes seules avec panama gagne pas des
leçons sur le réseau des enfants le
débat le débat c'est ça pourquoi vous
êtes choqué qu'on mette en avant les
mais c'est pas plus grave que ça vous
dérange moi personnellement je suis
choqué voilà pourquoi mais un enfant ça
se protège quand on fait un bon d'accord
vous mais vos enfants vous les mettez
sur les réseaux sociaux les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
gens malsains qui traînent sur les
réseaux sociaux on a des de toutes
sortes de gens malsains je vais pas de
donner des trucs mais il ya des
pédophiles il ya aujourd'hui on met nos
enfants sur les réseaux sociaux
d'accord c'est les enfants voilà les
colts d'accord sortie d'école le premier
enfant qu'on va voir ça va être le cas
ça va être le vôtre d'accord donc c'est
un vrai plan des ventes des enfants
couteau that dangereux que ces abus
lycée mais c'est très malsain
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les candidats de
télé réalité on peut se dire se font de
l'argent dessus tout le monde le sait
d'accord alors bizarrement comment est
née l'idée d'un bébé en effet très
simple les bdd star de télé réalité ils
ont 500 1000 followers habitent à
l'étranger donc déjà l'argument de
l'école il fonctionne pas c'est à dire
que souvent de ces candidats la habitent
dans des pays étrangers voient les dents
et des écoles qui sont assez sûr protégé
moi je suis aussi cynique que toi je
t'ai pas que enfin voilà que tu penses
que tu veux mais moi je suis convaincu
qu'il ya quand même un tout petit peu de
de naïveté dans la façon qu'ils ont
d'exposer leurs enfants en disant voilà
peut-être que il aura très tôt un compte
instagram
il va gagner des sous avec et moi aussi
je suis devenu client de ce truc là par
exemple la fille de le fils de carafes
et raghni qui s'appelle les eaux mais
tous les matins je le regarde
ça m'amuse je suis sam attendri alors je
suis maman voilà ils scandent de la
question elle est simple clairement est
ce que c'est un business
oui oui oui j'ai franchement je suis
très choqué et magali je pense que là
vous devriez intervenir vous ai déjà les
mains
vous êtes la papesse non mais pas dans
le débat pas dans le débat vous êtes la
papesse de tout ça c'est vous qui
organisez et là il ya une dérive
vraiment dangereux alors effectivement
laissez moi finir
effectivement on exhibe les enfants ce
qui se passe c'est que ces stars de
télé-réalité moi par exemple j'adore
nabila mais ces stars là elles ne
peuvent plus se montrer s'exhiber de la
même manière lorsqu'elles ont un enfant
donc elle trouve la méthode de l'enfant
pour continuer à exister en à billère
pour côte non c'est la seule qui ne met
pas en avant dieu bleu non mais vous
employer le mot cela est notre côté mais
elles ne peuvent le globalement elle au
pluriel
elle est il du soleil par an ils peuvent
plus faire de il se montrait
pareillement et donc ils prennent le
prisme de l'enfance est hyper dangereux
oui c'est rémunérateurs mais c'est
dangereux on va vers de graves dérives
et franchement il faut y mettre un terme
rachel alors en moi je trouve qu'il faut
savoir vivre avec son temps mais si on
reprend un exemple on parle aujourd'hui
des influenceurs mais certains comédiens
faisait ça aussi avec leurs enfants et à
l'époque ça a choqué ou pas certaines
personnes en exposant leurs buts et
leurs enfants dans la presse pour un
pot-de-vin au malawi aujourd'hui c'est
bien parce qu'aujourd'hui on vient avec
les réseaux sociaux c'est une autre
forme de bella c'est un gars vous avez
besoin clairement à but lucratif
aujourd'hui sur instagram où on les
utilise et moi sincèrement je suis pas
plus choqué que ça et on est les
premières regarder oui les poubelles le
duo gignac a jusqu'à un gain peut être
un attendri et je suis pas voilà jeu a
reçu un blâme ensuite tu n as qu à part
vos propos qui sont en effet très noble
quand on vous entend mais moi je
comprends que ça le choc je fais preuve
alors d'être choqués voilà les restes ça
reste une forme de voyeurisme et mais
moi je moi je prends mes nièces censure
en vidéo sur instagram avec moi je veux
voir exploite pas moi qui le met une
fois de temps en temps je dénigre pas ça
ces enfants tout le monde a envie de
montrer la beauté des enfants c'est
quelque chose de normal d'accord
maintenant de leur créer un compte
instagram tous les jours l'alimenter
avec des photos jour navire moi j'ai que
ça à content pour mes nièces que
j'alimente et l
un conteur raconte un salon dire et moi
on mélange tout cela s'est passé pour
aider vos enfants mission parce que je
parle pas de ça elles sont elles sont
superbes mais voilà je l'aimé et on fait
des vidéos et elles ont alors eu des
excuses
une première chose c'est que pour
protéger ces enfants déjà peu vite et
faire une vidéo volant parce que les
enfants des autres on peut les tuer
comme ça donc ensuite deuxièmement je
vois pas en quoi on monétise un enfant
et en quoi on se fait du blé parce que
je reprend les termes sur les enfants
aujourd'hui carla mais je ne sais pas
encore quand même content car l'ensemble
ensemble d'accords moi j'ai aucun enfant
là dans les gens qu'on a montré qui a
été monétisées c'est à dire qu'il n'ya
aucun de ces candidats là d'accord on à
monétiser l'image de son nom fait ses
preuves en même temps pendant lequel est
bien saison mais ce à dire que vous
c'est très pervers comme idée parce que
vous faites un buzz de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas et c'est vous qui avez des
idées pervers parce qu'en réalité ces
gens là n'ont jamais demandé le moindre
centime pour faire faire la promotion
alors vous avez alors c'est pas sans
suite
ensuite deuxième et ça je le sais et je
pense que dans ces six mois je suis un
bruit deuxièmement pour information
quand ils ont tourné la vidéo de carla
donc du petit bébé ruby d'accord ils ont
touché un cachet qui a été directement
placée sur le compte de la petite
d'accord c'est à dire que la petite
effectivement tout a été placé sur un
compte épargne à petit c'est un cachet
de production d'accord ce n'est pas de
la publicité n'a pas de promotion un
déguisement ça non mais magali ce banal
à la bouche sont les mots voilés pouvais
pas dire non mais non mais non de
l'argent et souhaite pas prédire généré
donc c'est les parents ne change pas non
en même temps mais non mais je l'aimé
destination quand un influenceur met en
scène des enfants ça va leur créer la
popularité donc de l'audience et lors de
l'audience à cette dramatisation sur
leur compte c'est de cette manière dont
on aura de la violence quand vous est
fixé ce serait candidat télé réalité qui
vive
nabil alors on la connaît depuis
calathes 17 ou 18 ans d'accord
aujourd'hui elle a grandi ces gens là
les ans les gens les aiment ils ont un
public qu'il faut respecter
on a besoin de voir comment ils
grandissent calais la vie quelqu'un
c'est la réalité avoir un enfant
aujourd'hui c'est la vraie vie c'est
vous quel père mère à chaque fois qu'on
parle de ça et qu'est-ce qu'ils
admettent dans un enfant qu'on monte sur
instagram c'est beau un bébé toutes les
photos convoité petit truc là le peloton
il n'a pas tord motion donc là alors on
va conclure donc pour vous et pour le
jeu ce soit clair aucun de ces candidats
là ne se fait de l'argent en mettant
leurs enfants sont installés pour nous
aussi ok mais quand ils se font filmer
en train d'accoucher me dites pas que
c'est compté oui c'est faux propagation
vide
en fait la téléralité ses coiffeurs gens
moi vous êtes bien passé pouvoir ce que
la téléralité la téléralité s'est
montrée la vie des gens les voient que
voir comment les évolué et est un peu
d'air avec abba on dort pas